Unterwegs
auf der Suche nach dem Glück.
Das ist "Reporter Spezial".
Und das hier ist keine normale
Tramfahrt, sondern eine Wallfahrt.
Macht Glauben glücklich?
Das versuche ich herauszufinden.
Und bei mir ist Beat Schlatter:
Komiker,
Schauspieler und Stadtzürcher.
Wusstest du, dass es in der Stadt
Zürich einen Wallfahrtsort gibt?
Ja, ja, das ist ...
Man sieht hier viele Pilger
und musste die Schuhe ausziehen
beim Einsteigen.
Im Ernst, in Zürich Seebach?
- Ich wusste es natürlich nicht.
Das muss mir
jemand aus der Ostschweiz erklären.
Das ist bitter:
Du wusstest es nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt: Die meisten,
die ich frage, haben keine Ahnung.
Wir schauen uns das mal an.
- Ich freue ich wahnsinnig.
Hast du es etwas mit dem Heiligen?
- Ich wäre gern ein Heiliger.
Aber es passiert einfach nichts.
Du bist reformiert, oder?
- Reformiert, ja, aber ...
Ich habe z.B. ...
Sagt dir Antonius etwas?
Oh, schau jetzt!
Jetzt, hier. Siehst du es?
Das ist es.
- Ah! Aber dieser Antonius ...
... ist mein Lieblingsheiliger.
Wenn dir etwas abhanden kommt -
nicht nur Materielles ...
Wenn du ihm gut zuredest,
kommt das wieder zurück.
Du musst gar nicht so ... Es stimmt.
- Das funktioniert?
Da kamen schon Dinge zum Vorschein -
das glaubst du nicht.- Also gut.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Kapelle der
heiligen Maria, nicht von Antonius.
Aber vielleicht
gefällt sie dir trotzdem.
Man könnte jetzt meinen,
das sei die Kirche.
Aber das ist sie nicht.
Wir müssen den Hintereingang finden.
Ich vermute, dass du mir
noch etwas anderes zeigen willst.
* Sphärische Orgelmusik *
Du hast ja Erfahrung mit Kirchen.
Du hast für "reformiert."
fast 20 Pfarrer/-innen interviewt.
Was genau interessiert dich
an diesem Thema?
Natürlich die Menschen
und der Beruf Pfarrer.
Beim Fussball bin ich z.B.
mit Fredy Bickel befreundet.
So sehe ich hinter die Kulissen
einer Fussballmannschaft.
Oder Pascale Bruderer zeigt mir,
wie es hinter den Kulissen
der Politik ...
Wolltest du hinter die Kulissen
des Glaubens blicken?
Aber auch, weil es für dich selbst
ein Thema ist?
Es ist für mich ein Thema
und auch immer eine Inspiration,
Leute, die etwas komplett anderes
machen als ich, kennenzulernen,
sich auszutauschen -
das ist irrsinnig.
Jetzt stehen wir hier,
du bist reformiert, ich bin es auch.
Was bedeuten für dich
katholische Wallfahrtsorte?
Bei den Katholiken gibt es einige
Heilige, die ich irrsinnige finde.
Z.B. eben Antonius.
- Der, der Verlorenes wiederfindet?
Genau, man muss ihm gut zureden
oder einige sagen,
man müsse ihm etwas Geld hinlegen -
es geht auch ohne Geld.
Oder auch Pater Pio, der auch
schaut, dass es einem gut geht.
Ich merke: Dafür hast du ein Flair.
- Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Das sind für mich Helden,
wie es in der Rockmusik Helden gibt
oder in der Politik
oder im Fernsehen Heldinnen gibt.
Auch die Muttergottes
ist für viele Menschen eine Heldin.
Sie kommen dann hierher,
in diese Filiale.
Das hier ist ja
"das kleine Lourdes von Zürich",
eine Filiale
des richtigen Lourdes in Frankreich.
Sie kommen hierher an diesen Ort.
Beat, auch du hast einen Kraftort.
Es ist keine Kirche,
sondern etwas ganz anderes.
Im Lauf der Sendung zeigst du ihn
mir. Zuerst gehen wir hier rein.
Meine Kollegin Helen Arnet
hat hier zwei Tage lang beobachtet,
wer an diesen Ort kommt und warum.
* Geflüstertes Gebet
in einer fremden Sprache *
* Sphärische Orgelmusik *
Macht Sie das Glauben an die Madonna
glücklich?
Ja, sehr, sehr glücklich.
Sie hilft mir oft, sehr oft.
Ich weiss nicht, was sagen,
aber Madonna hilft mir sehr oft.
Sie hilft mir sehr oft.
Darum komme ich jeden Donnerstag
und Freitag hier beten.
La vierge Marie,
je vous demande merci, merci, merci,
je vous demande pardon, pardon
pour tout le mal que j'ai fait,
pour tout le bien que j'ai fait.
Gloire à Dieu.
Alléluia, amen, la vierge Marie.
Amen.
Marie ist sehr, sehr gut.
Was ist so gut an Maria?
Maria gibt das Leben.
Viel Leben - für mich.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es für andere ist.
Aber für mich -
ich bin sehr zufrieden mit Marie.
Es ist ein spezieller Ort,
sehr speziell.
Wir sehen in den Körper hinein -
ein sehr schönes Gefühl.
So frei.
Das gibt wirklich viel Energie,
nicht nur Hoffnung.
Und das ist sehr schön für uns alle.
Das zu tun,
ist wirklich sehr speziell.
Ich mag diese Kapelle sehr.
Ich komme schon regelmässig,
aber nicht sehr oft.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht katholisch,
habe mit Maria eigentlich
sozusagen gar nichts zu tun.
Aber es herrscht hier
eine Atmosphäre,
die mir irgendetwas gibt,
irgendetwas Schönes, Beruhigendes.
Ich bin reformiert, ich bin gläubig.
Macht Glauben Sie glücklich?
Ja. Und stark.
Und optimistisch. Und zufrieden.
Maria hilft.
Und die Wallfahrenden sind dankbar.
Sie bringen Blumen, spenden Geld und
entzünden schon die nächste Kerze,
um ihren Gebetsanliegen
zusätzlichen Nachdruck zu verleihen.
Wir kommen fast jede Woche
einmal hierher.
Dann bleiben wir ein wenig hier.
Denn unsere Maria ist die Beste!
Die Wände der Grotte
zieren unzählige sog. Votivtafeln,
sichtbare Zeichen
der vielen Gebetserhörungen,
die hier stattgefunden haben.
In Auftrag gegeben nicht nur
von Christen aller Konfessionen.
Auch Muslime, Buddhisten und Hindus
suchen und finden hier Hilfe.
Ihre Geschichten erzählen sie oft
der Sakristanin der Grotte.
Vor etwa einem halben Jahr
war immer
ein Hindu, ein Tamile hier.
Über zehn Jahre lang wartete er auf
einen positiven Bescheid aus Bern,
damit er seine Frau aus Sri Lanka
hierherholen darf.
Unter Tränen erzählte er mir,
dass er zu Maria kommt
und bittet, dass sie ihm hilft.
Und hilft Maria?
Ich habe ihn dann
ein zweites Mal gesehen.
Strahlend kam er -
zusammen mit seiner Frau
und einer Goldkette,
die er Maria schenken wollte.
Auch in der angrenzenden Hauptkirche
Maria Lourdes Seebach
wird ständig gebetet -
sieben Tage die Woche,
von morgens früh bis abends.
Immer wieder fällt mir eine Frau auf,
stundenlang ins Gebet vertieft.
Kirchen, die der Muttergottes
geweiht sind ...
Sie ist eine Art Autobahn
zu Jesus Christus.
Für mich sind sie speziell.
Das kann man wohl nicht
in Worte fassen.
Aber es ist eine Art Autobahn
zum himmlischen Vater,
es geht einfach irgendwie schneller
mit ihrer Hilfe.
Susanne Oetterli hatte vor 17 Jahren
ein Bekehrungserlebnis -
eine eigentliche Wäsche
aus Licht und Liebe, wie sie sagt.
Macht Glauben glücklich?
- Oh ja!
Ich wüsste nicht, wo ich ohne wäre,
und ich möchte nie mehr ohne sein,
weil er Orientierung, Kraft und
diese riesengrosse Zuversicht gibt
und v.a. diese unglaubliche Liebe,
in die man eingehüllt wird,
die es auf der Erde
wirklich nicht gibt.
Wenn man das mal erfahren hat,
kann man gar nicht anders.
Man sehnt sich,
hat so eine Sehnsucht nach der Liebe
zum himmlischen Vater,
dass man gar nicht mehr anders kann.
Es klingt speziell,
aber es ist auch speziell.
Es ist ein Geschenk,
eine solche Wäsche zu bekommen.
Mir ist die Muttergottes erschienen.
Das hat mich völlig verändert.
Ich komme fast jede Woche einmal
in diese Lourdes-Kapelle.
Das war folgendermassen:
Die Muttergottes
erschien mir etwa achtmal.
Achtmal. Achtmal erschienen.
- Hier drin?
Hier drin, ja. Achtmal.
Wie sah sie aus?
Gewöhnlich, nicht,
wie sie in der Bibel abgebildet ist.
Eine gewöhnliche Frau - wie Sie.
Mit Jea... Trug sie Jeans?
Das weiss ich nicht mehr.
Sie war jedenfalls modern gekleidet.
Ich dachte: Diese Frau habe ich doch
schon mal irgendwo gesehen.
Ich machte mir nicht viele Gedanken.
Das war das erste Mal.
Sie hat mir hier zugelächelt.
Und sie machte so, sie winkte.
Ich dachte: "Wer ist diese Frau?
Eine so schöne Frau!"
Und sie meinte mich.
Was bin ich denn?
Von seinem Erlebnis
zeugt eine Votivtafel in der Grotte.
Das sind Sie?
- Ja. Roland Markus Schaub.
Das mache ich oft.
- Was ist das?
Das bringt Glück.
Das ist Weihwasser.
Die Schauplatz-Reportage
aus der Kapelle Maria Lourdes.
Und hier ist Helen Arnet,
unsere Reporterin,
die - wir wussten es auch nicht -
offenbar Ähnlichkeiten mit Maria hat.
Offenbar.
Mir ist bei der Reportage
aufgefallen:
Es hat hier sehr viele Leute
aus anderen Ländern
und praktisch keine Schweizer.
War das in diesen zwei Tagen so?
- Ja.
Es ist nicht so, dass die Schweizer
nicht hier gewesen wären,
aber sie haben sich
nicht so geöffnet.
Die Menschen
mit Migrationshintergrund
haben einfach laut, fröhlich
und sehr mutig ...
Auch selbstbewusst
von ihrem Glauben geredet.
Sie waren stolz.
Die Menschen
ohne Migrationshintergrund,
Herr Müller und Frau Meier,
haben mir auch Dinge erzählt.
Ich war wirklich erstaunt:
Sie erzählten gern und freuten sich,
dass ich sie nach dem Glauben fragte
und nach diesem Ort.
Aber sie wollten keine Interviews
vor der Kamera geben.
Wir müssen wohl offen lassen,
warum das so ist.
Aber es deckt sich schon
mit meinem Eindruck,
dass in unserem Leben in der Schweiz
Glauben öffentlich
kein grosses Thema ist.
Ja,
auch diese Leute haben gern erzählt.
Was haben sie dir z.B. erzählt?
Z.B. eine Mutter, die Probleme mit
ihrer pubertierenden Tochter hat.
Sie sagte,
die Tochter verhalte sich nicht gut,
sie umgebe sich mit den falschen
Freunden und Freundinnen.
Sie ging wirklich täglich
zur Muttergottes beten,
dass die Tochter wieder
in gute Kreise kommt,
sich wieder gut verhält.
Oder eine Frau hat mir erzählt,
sie habe ihre private Wallfahrt
hierher gemacht.
Ihre Schwester hat Krebs
und sie wandert jede Woche einmal
von ihrem Wohnort hierher und betet.
Denn sie hat von einer Freundin
gehört, dass ihr das geholfen hat,
dass sie quasi
den Krebs besiegen konnte.
Solche Geschichten
habe ich hier gehört.
Oder auch einen Eventmanager
habe ich hier getroffen.
Er sagte,
er komme jetzt täglich hierher,
denn seine Zukunft sei so ungewiss,
dass er eigentlich
vor dem Nichts stehe.
Grossveranstaltungen sind verboten.
Er erzählte mir, er sei
in dieser Zeit hierhergekommen
und habe hier Zuversicht gewonnen.
Er habe hier eine Einsicht gehabt.
Er sagte, er habe hier gespürt,
dass er nicht mehr Reichtum
anhäufen müsse.
Er habe hier gemerkt,
dass er auf  e i n e m  Stuhl
an  e i n e m  Tisch sitzen könne.
Er hat hier
eine Art neue Ausrichtung gefunden.
Du kennst diese Kapelle sehr gut,
hast deine Lizenziatsarbeit
darüber geschrieben.
Damals warst du
ein Jahr nonstop hier.
Woher kommt dein persönliches
Interesse an diesen Themen?
Ich bin im katholischen
Kanton Luzern aufgewachsen.
Die Schulmesse gehörte dazu.
Nach Ostern hatte ich immer das
Gefühl, ich sei ziemlich ergriffen.
Aber dann verflachte es.
Dann habe ich in dieser
Stadt Zürich, in diesem Seebach
einen Wallfahrtsort gesehen,
in einem so städtischen Gebiet.
Das hat mich
wahnsinnig interessiert.
In einer reformierten Stadt
ein Marienwallfahrtsort -
das fand ich spannend.
Wenn du an diese zwei Tage
zurückdenkst -
würdest du sagen,
Glauben macht glücklich?
Die Leute, mit denen ich gesprochen
habe, würden das ganz klar bejahen.
Ich glaube es, ja.
- Was denkst du, warum?
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
Ich hatte hier eine Begegnung
mit einem Geschäftsmann,
der mit dem Aktenkoffer
unter dem Arm täglich vorbeikam.
Er erzählte mir,
Glauben mache glücklich,
weil Glauben für ihn bedeute,
Vertrauen zu haben.
Er machte ein Beispiel und sagte:
"Wenn Sie im Internet
ein Kleid bestellen,
wissen Sie, dass es ankommt."
"Sie fragen nicht täglich nach,
ob es schon auf der Post sei."
So sei es für ihn mit dem Glauben.
Wenn er ein Anliegen habe,
deponiere er es
und wisse, dass es kommt,
er müsse nicht immer nachfragen.
Das verleiht wohl einen Boden,
ein Getragen-Sein.
Ich glaube, das Wissen,
dass irgendjemand zu einem schaut,
macht schon glücklich.
Diese Filiale von Lourdes
ist ein ganz kleiner Ort,
den Menschen besuchen,
es gibt viel grössere Pilgerorte.
Einen davon hast du für die Sendung
"Reporter" 2011 besucht,
das war in Medjugorje in Bosnien.
Dorthin gehen jährlich
3 Mio. Menschen,
darunter auch Pilger aus der Schweiz.
Der Engel des Herrn
brachte Maria die Botschaft:
"Gegrüsst seist du, Maria,
voll der Gnade,
der Herr ist mit dir. Du bist
gebenedeit unter den Frauen."
"Und gebenedeit
ist die Frucht deines Leibes."
Dies ist die Geschichte
von Adelbert Imboden
und seinem Herzensort Medjugorje.
Imboden
ist professioneller Wallfahrtsführer
und nimmt uns mit auf eine Reise nach
Medjugorje in Bosnien-Herzegowina.
Auf einem Hügel nahe des Dorfes
ereignete sich im Juni 1981
Wundersames:
Fünf Kinder berichteten,
ihnen sei eine unglaublich schöne
junge Frau erschienen,
die sich als die heilige
Jungfrau Maria zu erkennen gab.
Diese Erscheinungen
wiederholten sich danach täglich -
angeblich bis zum heutigen Tag.
(Mehrere Menschen beten)
Im Vertrauen auf deine Liebe ...
Maria ist allgegenwärtig
in Medjugorje, auch in der Pension,
wo Adelbert Imboden
seine Walliser Wallfahrtsgruppe
für eine Woche einquartiert hat.
Die meisten der Anwesenden
waren schon fünf- oder zehn-
oder gar 15-mal hier.
# ... Wort zu mir gesagt.
Verschmäh nicht unser Gebet
in unseren Nöten,
sondern erlöse uns ...
Zweimal pro Monat
erscheint die Gottesmutter
den heute erwachsenen Seherkindern
unter den Augen der Öffentlichkeit.
Um meine Neugier zu stillen,
führt Adelbert Imboden mich
in ein Fotostudio.
Dort zeigt man mir Aufnahmen
der letzten öffentlichen Erscheinung.
* Mystische Musik *
Zu Tausenden
strömen die Pilger dann jeweils
auf den sog. Erscheinungsberg,
um dabei zu sein,
wenn Seherin Mirjana
die Gottesmutter Maria sieht
und ihren Botschaften lauscht.
Mirjana ist eines der damaligen
Seherkinder und heute 55 Jahre alt.
Ihr und zwei anderen Sehern erscheint
die Gottesmutter seit 1981 -
für die Teilnehmenden an der
Erscheinung bleibt Maria unsichtbar.
Die Botschaften, die sie
von der Muttergottes empfangen hat,
lässt Mirjana
im Anschluss an die Erscheinung
aufschreiben und übersetzen.
"Liebe Kinder, der Vater hat euch
nicht euch selbst überlassen."
"Jene, die meinem Sohn folgen,
denken an den Bruder in Christus
wie an sich selbst und
sie kennen die Selbstsucht nicht."
"Darum wünsche ich, dass ihr
das Licht meines Sohnes seid,
dass ihr all jenen, die den Vater
nicht kennengelernt haben,
all jenen, die in der Finsternis
der Sünde, Verzweiflung,
Pein und Einsamkeit umherirren,
den Weg erleuchtet."
"Ich danke euch."
Für Adelbert Imboden sind diese
Botschaften Wegweiser durchs Leben.
Zweifel an deren Echtheit
oder an der Glaubwürdigkeit der Seher
lässt er gar nicht erst aufkommen.
Mein Glaube ist inzwischen so fest,
dass ich mir sage: Ich glaube das.
Ich glaube, was hier passiert.
Wenn ich nur schon
in meiner Pilgergruppe sehe,
was in diesen Jahren
alles an Positivem passiert ist:
seelische, körperliche Heilungen,
Ehen, die am Zerbrechen waren usw.,
sogar der Priesterberuf - das ist
alles dank Medjugorje passiert.
Ein Bischof sagt sogar,
er hätte 60 % der Priester
in seinem Bistum nicht,
wenn Medjugorje nicht wäre,
das sagt ein Bischof in Österreich.
Warum soll ich als kleiner Adelbert
denn daran zweifeln?
Medjugorje ist Glaubenssache.
Und so führt Adelbert Imboden
seine Pilgergruppe
zu einer sehr anschaulichen
Einführung
in die Geheimnisse von Medjugorje
und seiner Seherinnen und Seher.
Herzlich willkommen in der
Gemeinschaft der Seligpreisungen.
Mein Name ist
Schwester Teresia Benedicta.
Ich möchte Sie heute in die Bot-
schaften von Medjugorje einführen.
Der Unterschied zwischen Medjugorje
und den anderen Erscheinungsorten
ist ihre physische Präsenz.
Maria kommt jeden Tag
physisch mit ihrem Körper.
Wenn Sie diese Statue anschauen -
das ist die typische Mama
von Medjugorje.
Sie kommt mit ihrem
alltäglichen Nazareth-Kleid.
Es ist ein Alltagskleid,
sie kommt in unseren Alltag.
Sie hat blaue Augen,
sie hat zwölf Sterne als Krone,
sie schwebt immer auf einer Wolke.
Im Himmel sind die Heiligen.
Wollen Sie heilig werden?
Ja, alle. Wir müssen alle
heilig werden wollen.
Die da oben beten für uns
und wir da oben beten
für die armen Seelen im Fegefeuer.
Und die armen Seelen im Fegefeuer
beten auch für uns.
Ma hört es bei uns nicht mehr,
ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass man bei uns in einer Predigt
von Fegefeuer und Hölle hört.
Das gibt es ja heute nicht mehr,
Jesus ist der Barmherzige,
er vergibt alles.
Jesus ist eigentlich schon
der Gerechte.
Und wenn er gerecht ist,
muss es ja auch ein Fegefeuer
und eine Hölle geben.
Das war immer die Lehre
der katholischen Kirche.
* Klagende Blasmusik *
* Rhythmische Perkussion *
Betend führt Adelbert Imboden
seine 20-köpfige Pilgergruppe
an den Fuss des Erscheinungsberges,
wo die Gottesmutter Maria
den Seherkindern erstmals erschien.
Mehrere Millionen Gläubige
pilgern jedes Jahr nach Medjugorje,
obwohl Rom erst letztes Jahr
die offizielle Erlaubnis
für diese Wallfahrten erteilt hat.
... vor dem Feuer der Hölle und
führe alle Seelen in den Himmel.
Heilige Maria, Muttergottes,
bitte für uns Sünder,
jetzt und in der Stunde
unseres Todes, amen.
* Sphärische Musik *
Ich glaube,
das ist einer der speziellsten Orte.
Es ist irgendwie ein Ort
mit viel Kraft,
der sehr geheimnisvoll ist.
Es gibt hier viele Emotionen,
vieles wird gelöst.
Man bekommt irgendwie Kraft.
Auch im ruhigen November platzt
die Kirche des Heiligen Jakobus
während des vierstündigen
Abendprogrammes aus allen Nähten
und die Gläubigen
lauschen den Worten der Priester,
die auf einer eigenen Radiofrequenz
simultan übersetzt werden.
Gegen 150-mal war Adelbert Imboden
schon in Medjugorje.
Doch jetzt, beim Abschiedslied
um 6 Uhr in der Früh,
bricht dem Pilgerleiter die Stimme.
# ... du bist meine Mutter, du.
# Maria, meine Mutter,
du bist meine Mutter, du.
# Gospa, Majka moja, Kraljica mira.
Es ist einfach ein Schmerz,
von dieser Energie,
dieser Kraft und Umgebung hier
wieder nach Hause in den Alltag
zu gehen, dort zu kämpfen.
Und hier ist ein Teil des Himmels.
Das macht mich schon etwas traurig.
* Majestätische Orchestermusik *
Jetzt ist Adelbert Imboden
bei mir in Zürich Seebach.
Es gibt sicher Menschen,
die diesen Film
über die Marienerscheinungen
anschauen und sagen:
"Das ist alles Betrug, das stimmt
gar nicht, das ist Gehirnwäsche."
Was sagen Sie denen?
Ich persönlich lasse das stehen,
ich greife der Kirche nicht vor.
Wenn die Kirche sagt, Medjugorje
sei akzeptiert und anerkannt,
akzeptiere ich das auch.
Ganz persönlich muss ich sagen: Ich
habe keine Minute daran gezweifelt,
dass es die Muttergottes ist.
Aber Sie
als Adelbert Imboden aus Brig,
haben Sie die Muttergottes
schon mal gesehen?
Nein, nein.
Aber ich kenne Pilger,
die die Muttergottes gesehen haben,
die mir jedenfalls gesagt haben,
sie hätten sie gesehen.
Aber ich persönlich
lege keinen grossen Wert darauf,
ob ich die Muttergottes sehe
oder nicht.
Was finden Sie selbst im Glauben?
Bezogen auf Ihren Alltag,
wenn Sie nicht wallfahren,
was tut der Glaube,
wo zeigt er sich in Ihrem Alltag?
Ich persönlich habe in all
den Jahren v.a. vertrauen gelernt.
Ich habe viel mehr Vertrauen
und erledige meine Sache
viel mehr mit Maria oder mit Jesus.
Was heisst das?
D.h., wenn ich ein grösseres Problem
oder so habe,
trete ich durch das Gebet
mit Jesus in Kontakt.
Ich verhandle viel mehr mit ihm
oder mit der Muttergottes.
Das gibt mir eine wahnsinnige Kraft.
Ohne Glauben könnte ich
eigentlich nicht mehr sein.
Ja, aber es gab einmal
einen Adelbert Imboden ohne,
oder mit weniger Glauben.
Sie waren in der Immobilienbranche,
haben v.a. gearbeitet in Ihrem Leben,
es hatte nicht viel anderes Platz.
Und dann gab es einen Moment,
in dem sich das gewendet hat.
Was ist damals passiert?
Das war ein ganz spezieller Moment.
Ich war auf dem Weg zur Arbeit
und hatte eine Begegnung.
Über diese Begegnung
habe ich noch nie geredet
und ich will auch nicht
darüber reden.
Also etwas, das Sie tief berührt hat.
- Ja.
Durch diese Begegnung
habe ich mein Leben geändert.
Wenn Adelbert Imboden von früher,
der v.a. mit Immobilien zu tun hatte,
Ihnen jetzt begegnen würde - wäre es
möglich, dass er auch sagen würde:
"Das mit dieser Muttergottes
und so viel Religion ..."
"Ach, ich weiss nicht,
ob das stimmt."
Ja, es ist natürlich schon möglich,
dass Adelbert ...
Ich war eigentlich auch einer,
der das vorher gesagt hat.
Ich ging zwar regelmässig
sonntags in die Kirche,
lebte aber nicht unbedingt
einen tiefen Glauben.
Durch Medjugorje
habe ich doch gelernt,
was es heisst,
den Glauben tief zu leben.
D.h., nicht nur in die Kirche
und wieder hinauszugehen, sondern:
Was passiert in der Kirche? Was kann
ich für mein Alltagsleben mitnehmen?
Und so bin ich auch gewachsen.
Daher sind das
zwei ganz verschiedene Adelberts,
vorher und nachher.
Ich hatte vorher auch
ganz andere Freundschaften.
Jetzt habe ich andere Freunde,
das sind Pilger.
Vorher waren es Immobilienleute.
- Ja.
Haben Sie dadurch,
dass Sie zum Glauben gefunden haben,
auch Leute verloren,
weil sie gesagt haben ...
Ja, ich habe alle oder
fast alle Freundschaften verloren,
weil sie damit
nichts anfangen konnten.
Aber andererseits
habe ich neue Menschen gewonnen,
die mir viel mehr geben
für mein persönliches Leben.
In diesem Leben bin ich heute
sehr, sehr glücklich.- Mhm.
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
Glauben macht glücklich?- Ja.
Ja. Aber wirklich Glauben
und nicht Wissen.
Das ist das Problem
der heutigen Zeit:
dass man meint, man könne
alles diskutieren, alles zerreden.
Ich bin diesbezüglich sehr einfach:
Ich glaube.
* Mona lacht. *
Sie glauben? Sie wollen
nichts wissen, Sie glauben einfach?
Ja, wenn die katholische Kirche
etwas vorgibt,
das in der heiligen Schrift steht,
will ich das nicht zerreden.
Aber man kann das Hirn
nicht einfach ausschalten.
Nein, das mache ich auch nicht.
- Aha.
Aber ich gebe mir Mühe,
mit dem zu leben, was da ist,
und nicht immer alles
zu hinterfragen.
Denn dann komme ich nie
in einen tiefen Glauben.
Man kann heute alles hinterfragen.
Darum ist unsere Welt
so komplex und kompliziert.- Genau.
Kann man also sagen:
"Glauben macht glücklich,
weil es das Leben einfacher macht"?
Ja,
das ist jetzt vielleicht sehr ...
Ja, aber es geht in diese Richtung.
Wenn man
einen richtig tiefen Glauben hat,
bin ich der Meinung,
dass man viel erreichen kann,
viel mehr als ohne Glauben.
Manche Menschen pilgern nicht
an einen Ort, den sie schon kennen,
sondern einfach, weil sie sich
auf den Weg machen wollen.
Z.B. Raphael Grubenmann wollte
nach Santiago de Compostela pilgern,
ging aber wegen Corona nicht.
Deshalb hat ihn
unser Reporter Hanspeter Bäni
auf einer Pilgerreise
durch die Schweiz begleitet.
* Monotone Gitarrenmusik *
Ich bin Raphael Grubenmann, bin 25
und gehe in diesem Jahr
auf den Jakobsweg.
Was erhoffen Sie sich
auf dem Jakobsweg zu finden?
Wieder das Vertrauen und den Glauben
an mich zurückzugewinnen.
Und auch ...
die Verbindung zur Natur
und zur Erde, mich wieder zu erden.
Das ist meine Freundin, mit ihr
bin ich schon drei Jahre zusammen.
Wir haben
verschiedene gemeinsame Ziele,
wie z.B. ein schönes Haus mit Pool,
und Träume, die aber nicht
wegen des Status wichtig sind,
sondern weil wir uns das wünschen:
genug Platz, baden zu können
und auch frei zu sein.
Was sagt Ihre Freundin dazu,
dass Sie auf den Jakobsweg gehen?
Sie hat mir schon länger gesagt,
ich solle doch den Jakobsweg machen.
Sie hat mich in letzter Zeit
wirklich dazu getrieben:
"Hey, geh mal!"
"Komm wieder zu dir selbst,
finde den Glauben wieder an dich
und das Vertrauen in dich!"
In letzter Zeit,
durch die sehr turbulente Zeit,
habe ich dies verloren.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
* Hundebellen *
Die Muschel ist ein Erkennungszeichen
für Pilger auf dem Jakobsweg.
Der alte Fernweg führt durch
Raphael Grubenmanns Wohnort Herisau.
Die Vier und die gelb stilisierte
Muschel weisen den Weg.
Er trägt etliche Konflikte
mit sich herum,
die an seinem Selbstvertrauen nagen.
Einerseits Verlustängste,
Existenzängste,
Ängste, Fehler zu machen,
wegen meiner Erfahrung,
dass ich in letzter Zeit
ziemlich viele Fehler gemacht habe.
Vielleicht sind es nicht mal Fehler.
Ich habe aber das Gefühl,
dass es Fehler sind.
Und ich gebe mir
die Verantwortung dafür,
etwas falsch gemacht zu haben.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass ich
in eine Spirale geraten bin:
Ich denke nur noch nach
und bin im Kopf.
Und daraus will ich herauskommen
und zur Ruhe kommen.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
Sie sind viel am Handy
mit der Freundin.
Sind Sie überhaupt auf dem Jakobsweg
oder noch eher bei der Freundin?
Noch eher bei der Freundin.
- Warum?
Ich vermisse sie.
Es ist schon ein Schritt,
einfach mal wegzugehen
und mehrere Tage
ohne die Freundin zu sein -
v.a.,
wenn man es noch nie gemacht hat.
Jeder muss mal lernen,
mit sich allein klarzukommen.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
Der Bodensee ist noch in Sichtweite.
Dort hinten liegen seine Geschäfte.
Der 25-Jährige ist
gelernter Betriebsunterhaltsfachmann.
Zusammen mit einem Partner machte er
sich vor einem Jahr selbstständig.
Die beiden
bauten ein Airbnb-Geschäft auf.
Hier entsteht eine Wohnung
für eine Mieterin von mir,
die noch zwei Monate länger
bleiben will.
Nun habe ich ihr
diese Möglichkeit hier gegeben.
Wir bauen hier um
und machen alles fertig.
Das richten wir extra
für die zwei Monate für sie ein.
Ich miete Wohnungen an,
richte sie ein für Airbnb,
also für Touristen, und vermiete sie
auf der Plattform Airbnb weiter.
Ist das
ein erfolgreiches Geschäftsmodell?
Ich würde sagen, die Lage macht
auch aus, dass es erfolgreich ist.
Raphael Grubenmann
vermietet mehrere Wohnungen.
Sie waren selbst während
der Corona-Krise gut ausgelastet.
Mittlerweile führt er sein Geschäft
allein weiter.
Mit seinem Geschäftspartner
hat er sich zerstritten.
Fast ein halbes Jahr ging das so,
immer hin und her.
Wir wussten beide nicht genau,
was wir machen sollten.
Ich war in einer Situation,
die nicht einfach war,
um die Trennung durchzustehen,
finanziell und psychisch.
Das macht es natürlich auch nicht
besser und es schmerzt mich auch.
Es geht ja nicht darum, dass ich ihn
nicht mochte als Person,
sondern dass es geschäftlich
nicht mehr funktioniert hat.
Traf Sie die Trennung
vom Geschäftspartner hart?
Sehr, v.a. kam es zu Beleidigungen
und er kam mit dem Anwalt.
Dieser hat mich auch fertiggemacht.
Er hat mich über Facebook,
über alle Medien ...
* Lautes Ausatmen *
Schwierig, schwierig.
* Melancholische
elektronische Klänge *
Nebst der Trennung
von seinem Geschäftspartner
kam noch ein weiterer Verlust hinzu:
Raphael Grubenmann
verlor an einen Betrüger Geld
im fünfstelligen Bereich.
Ich war aus heutiger Sicht naiv,
ich glaubte dem.
Er wickelte mich dann derart ein,
dass ich das Geld bezahlte.
Das war ein grosser Teil dessen,
was ich an der Börse verdient habe.
Auf einmal war es einfach weg,
ich stand ohne alles da,
ohne Geld, nichts,
das Konto im Minus.
Das war der letzte Gong für mich,
um zu sagen:
"Jetzt ist genug,
jetzt will ich gehen."
* Anschwellende Perkussion *
Unten im Tal liegt das Tagesziel:
St. Peterzell im Kanton St. Gallen.
Weil die Pilgerherbergen
aufgrund des Coronavirus
im Juni noch geschlossen sind,
übernachtet er in einem Hotel.
* Sanfte Harfenmusik *
Am zweiten Tag lebt er bereits
etwas mehr im Hier und Jetzt.
Es hat sich etwas verändert.
Ich habe immer noch
unruhig geschlafen,
aber der räumliche Abstand
zu zu Hause hilft.
Seit über 1'000 Jahren
pilgern Menschen
nach Santiago de Compostela
in Spanien.
Dort sollen die sterblichen Überreste
des Apostels Jakobus begraben liegen.
Der Schweizer Pilgerweg
wird im 15. Jh.
zum ersten Mal schriftlich erwähnt.
Er diente schon immer
der inneren Einkehr.
Neun von zehn Menschen
auf dem Jakobsweg
haben einen religiösen Hintergrund.
Sie suchen Vergebung
von ihren Sünden,
wünschen sich die Erfüllung einer
Bitte oder möchten gesund werden.
Essen sieht man Raphael Grubenmann
nicht oft.
Das hat seinen Grund.
Meine Mutter war alleinerziehend und
wir mussten immer aufs Geld schauen.
Wir hatten nicht immer genug Essen.
Dadurch wurde ich auch geprägt.
Wenn es mir psychisch nicht so gut
geht, esse ich auch heute weniger.
Heute essen Sie etwas mehr
als gestern.
Wie muss man das interpretieren?
Dasses mir besser geht als gestern.
Seine Mutter ist für ihn
eine wichtige Bezugsperson.
Hallo.- Hoi Raphael.
Schön, dass du hier bist.
Claudia Grubenmann
hat Raphaels Weltbild geprägt.
Katholisch erzogen fand sie später
zu einer Glaubensform,
die christliche Grundwerte
mit Spiritualität verbindet.
Ich glaube an mich selbst,
an Gott, dass er mir Kraft gibt,
dass ich das Leben und meinen Weg
schaffen kann.
Somit habe ich Vertrauen
und das gibt mir Kraft.
Was für eine Beziehung
haben Sie zu Raphael?
Eine schöne und tiefe.
Einfach, weil wir durch schwierige,
und nicht durch einfache Zeiten
gegangen sind.
Sie hat mir einfach immer
mit auf den Weg gegeben,
dieses Vertrauen in sich
zu bewahren
und auch in die Zukunft, wenn es mal
schlechter läuft im Leben.
Das hat mich
auf dem ganzen Lebensweg begleitet.
Ich gehe immer wieder
zu meiner Mutter zurück,
rede mit ihr,
schütte ihr auch mal das Herz aus
oder was auch immer.
Ihre ruhige Art hilft mir.
Was mein Vater z.B. weniger hat,
finde ich bei meiner Mutter:
diese Erdung.
Schon als Kind war Raphael Grubenmann
ein sensibler Einzelgänger.
Mit 17 hatte er eine Depression, weil
er keinen Sinn mehr im Leben sah.
Er überwand die Lebenskrise
auf einer Pilgerreise
durch Frankreich und Spanien.
Ich habe viele Krisen erlebt
in meinem Leben.
Die Depressionen
wurden jetzt anders als auch schon,
weil ich gemerkt habe,
wie toll das Leben sein kann.
Man muss beide Seiten sehen,
damit man weiss, ob es schön ist,
auf dieser Erde zu bleiben
oder nicht.
Also haben Sie sich
auch schon Gedanken gemacht,
freiwillig aus dem Leben zu scheiden?
Das war mit 17,
bevor ich mit 18 zum ersten Mal ...
Also vor dem Jakobsweg 2013
hatte ich schon gewisse Gedanken,
die dem ähnlich sind, ja.
Andere gehen zum Psychiater
oder nehmen Medikamente,
Sie machen den Jakobsweg.
Ist das die richtige Vermutung?
Ja.
Das ist meine Art,
meine Psyche zu heilen.
* Ergreifende Klaviermusik *
Jede dritte Person auf dem Jakobsweg
ist jünger als 30 Jahre.
Laut Pilgerbüro
in Santiago de Compostela
begeben sich etwa gleich viele Frauen
wie Männer auf den alten Fernweg.
Der Vorname des 25-Jährigen
könnte nicht treffender sein
für einen Menschen auf dem Jakobsweg.
In der christlichen Tradition
ist Raphael der Schutzpatron
der Reisenden und Pilger.
Oberhalb von Wattwil trifft er
auf die achtjährige Ramona.
Hallo. Was machst denn du da?
Zeug verkaufen.
- Zeug verkaufen?
Was verkaufst du denn? Steine?
- Glückssteine, Ringe, Konfi.
Den hier mit dem Marienkäfer.
2 Fr., gell?
Den hat meine Freundin gemalt.
- Ah, ja? Der ist schön.
Ich gebe dir 3 Fr.,
mir hat man auch immer mehr gegeben.
Danke.
- Bitte, gern geschehen.
Wie heisst du denn?
- Ramona.
Freut mich, ich bin Raphael.
Tschüss, Ramona!- Tschüss!
* Donnern *
Noch bevor der Regen einsetzt,
erreicht er das Tagesziel Wattwil.
* Erhabene Musik, Vogelzwitschern *
Mental geht es mir so lala,
ich habe etwas unruhig geschlafen,
also fast gar nicht.
Es ist vieles in mir vorgegangen.
Ja, es ist mir auch
vieles klar geworden.
Was denn?
Dass ich, dass ich ...
... mit mir selbst
ein wenig Geduld haben muss.
Er wird sich bewusst,
dass er Zeit braucht,
um sich mit sich selbst zu versöhnen.
Raphael Grubenmann
wünscht sich mehr Selbstvertrauen,
das er aufgrund seiner Erlebnisse
verloren hat.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
Die ersten Blessuren sind da.
Spüren Sie noch andere Dinge?
Ja, die Schultern sind
etwas verspannt und mein Nacken.
Und die Sehnen.
Mit den Sehnen
habe ich immer etwas Probleme,
wenn ich viel gehe und wenig ...
Ich muss viel trinken,
damit sie gut geschmiert sind.
Eine weitere Wunde,
die er heilen möchte,
ist seine Beziehung zu Geld.
Raphael Grubenmann
interessiert sich fürs Börsengeschäft
und erzielte dort schon
satte Gewinne.
Glücklich machte es ihn nicht.
Ich habe Reichtum
einfach immer mit Geld verbunden,
und wollte reich werden.
Durch die ganzen Jahre,
in denen ich auch
Erfahrungen gewonnen habe,
habe ich gemerkt, dass Reichtum
noch mehr beinhaltet als nur Geld.
Man muss erst den Reichtum
in sich selbst finden und behalten.
* Treibende Gitarrenmusik *
Am vierten Tag seiner Reise
führt der Weg über den Etzel.
Der Berg liegt zwischen dem Zürichsee
und dem Sihlsee.
In der von Corona dominierten Zeit
hat er noch keine anderen Pilger
angetroffen.
Im vergangenen Jahr
erreichten knapp 350'000 Menschen
zu Fuss das Ziel
in Santiago de Compostela.
Auf der Passhöhe
steht die Kapelle St. Meinrad.
Sie wurde zum ersten Mal
im 13. Jh. erwähnt.
Unzählige Pilger überquerten schon
die alte Teufelsbrücke bei Egg.
Ich merke, wenn ich räumlich
von der Situation Abstand erhalte,
wie jetzt auf dem Jakobsweg,
immer weiter von zu Hause wegkomme,
dass ich besser loslassen
und es aus einer Adlerperspektive
betrachten kann.
So ist es einfacher,
die Situation zu analysieren.
* Melancholische Gitarrenmusik *
Verschiedene Routen
des Schweizer Jakobswegs
laufen im Wallfahrtsort Einsiedeln
zusammen.
* Sanfte Flötenmusik *
In der Klosterkirche
bringen wir den Pilger in Kontakt
mit Pater Lorenz Moser.
Sind Sie zum ersten Mal
in Einsiedeln?
In Einsiedeln ...
Ja, so viel ich weiss, ja.
Hier im Kloster sicher,
das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Es ist sehr imposant.
- Eindrücklich, nicht?
Ja, sehr.
- Ja, ja.
Ich bin unterwegs,
um den Glauben an mich
und das Vertrauen in mich
wiederzufinden.- Das ist gut.
Ich erlebe es immer wieder,
dass der Glaube
eine tiefe ... Verankerung gibt,
eine Verwurzelung.
Das ist die Grundlage dessen,
was man auf einer höheren Ebene
oder an der Oberfläche
als Glück erlebt.
Dieses Verwurzelt-Sein
ist für mich die Grundlage,
um glücklich zu werden
und glücklich zu sein.
In welcher Form sich das Glück
dann zeigt, ist eine andere Frage.
Aber ich kann schon sagen,
dass der Glaube
im Grunde genommen glücklich macht.
Aber bis zum Lebensende sind wir
wahrscheinlich auf der Suche.
Ja, ich denke auch,
es ist ein lebenslanger Prozess.
Was einem sehr oft im Weg steht,
um glücklich zu werden, ist,
dass man auf zu sehr
auf gewisse Dinge fixiert ist
und an vielen Dingen festhält.
Je mehr man sich davon lösen kann,
umso eher ist es möglich,
eine Glückserfahrung zu machen.
Das ist genau das, was ich
auf dem Jakobsweg machen kann,
indem ich gehe und in der Natur bin:
loslassen.
Das konnte ich sehr schmerzhaft,
aber auch spannend erfahren.
Aber es ist wirklich sehr wichtig.
- Ja.
* Kirchenglocken *
Raphael Grubenmann
will auf dem Jakobsweg
bis nach Genf weiterwandern.
Vielleicht findet er auf seinem Weg
das, was er verloren hat:
den Glauben an sich selbst.
* Elektronische Musik *
Bei mir ist Mathias Binswanger,
Professor für Volkswirtschaftslehre,
aber auch Glücksforscher, er hat sich
intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt.
Ist der Zusammenhang zwischen Glauben
und Glück wissenschaftlich erforscht?
Ja,
es gibt wohl keinen Zusammenhang,
den man nicht
zu erforschen versucht hat.
Man kann feststellen, dass die
Forschungen grundsätzlich zeigen,
dass Menschen, die glauben,
glücklicher sind
als Menschen, die nicht glauben.
Das ist so?
Ja.
Womit hat das zu tun?
- Einerseits sicher damit,
dass man einen Sinn sieht
im ganzen Leben und Dasein.
Man hat auch eine Perspektive,
die über dieses Leben hinausgeht.
D.h., das Leben ist mit dem Tod
nicht einfach fertig,
sondern es gibt dann
eine weitere Realität im Jenseits.
Das sorgt wahrscheinlich auch
für eine gewisse Gelassenheit
dem Leben gegenüber, die sich
positiv auf das Glück auswirkt.
Ist das auch ersichtlich,
wenn man die Staaten-Rangliste
betrachtet in Sachen Glück?
Sind Länder,
in denen der Glaube eher stark ist,
glücklicher als säkulare Staaten?
Man muss natürlich aufpassen,
Glaube ist nicht gleich Glaube.
Ein Glaube
kann natürlich positiv sein,
er kann sich aber auch
schlimm auswirken für Menschen,
denn er kann zu einem
Herrschaftsinstrument werden.
Deshalb muss man sehr genau
hinschauen in einem Land,
was Glaube dort ganz genau heisst.
Gibt es einen Unterschied
in Sachen Religion?
Kann man sagen,
protestantische Gebiete
seien glücklicher als katholische
oder umgekehrt?
Betrachtet man die Länder,
könnte man zum Schluss kommen,
dass Menschen
in protestantischen Ländern
glücklicher sind als Menschen
in katholischen Ländern.
Denn die Länder, die in
diesem Glücks-Ranking vorne liegen,
zumindest in Europa, sind immer
die skandinavischen Länder
und die Schweiz.
Das sind alles Länder,
die relativ stark reformiert sind.
Da spielt aber wahrscheinlich
der social desirability bias
eine grosse Rolle.
D.h., protestantische Länder
haben meist auch
ein starkes Pflichtgefühl.
Die Menschen sagen: "Man muss
damit zufrieden sein, was man hat."
"Doch, wir sind glücklich."
- "Man darf sich nicht beschweren."
Deshalb wird es in diesen Ländern
wohl auch übertrieben dargestellt.
Während in katholischen Ländern,
die gleichzeitig meist
die südlicheren Länder sind,
die mediterranen Länder,
das Gefühl,
man müsse doch zufrieden sein,
nicht so ausgeprägt ist.
Betrachtet man es dann insgesamt,
ist meiner Meinung nach
wahrscheinlich der Katholizismus
dem Glück doch förderlicher.
weil er meist mit einer ausgeprägten
Doppelmoral verbunden ist.
Das ist
wie der Fünfer und das Weggli:
Man ist zwar einerseits religiös,
kann aber gleichzeitig auch
alles Mögliche machen.
Man ist auch dem Genuss
nicht abgeneigt im Katholizismus,
im Protestantismus viel mehr.
Ich glaube,
dass eine gut gepflegte Doppelmoral
dem Glück sehr förderlich ist.
Karl Marx sagt,
Religion sei das Opium des Volks.
Ist das so, statistisch?
Ist Glauben wie eine Glücksdroge?
Ich würde sagen: immerhin.
Es ist doch gut,
wenn Glauben Opium fürs Volk ist.
Man raucht Opium ja, weil man in
einen gewissen Zustand kommen will,
in dem man auch glücklich ist.
Das können wir letztlich
nicht entscheiden.
Wir wissen nicht,
ob es einen Gott gibt oder nicht,
ob es sinnvoll ist, zu glauben,
oder nicht.
Also was Opium ist und was nicht,
können wir gar nicht entscheiden.
Ja. Also gibt es vielleicht
schlechtere Drogen als den Glauben?
Ja, am Schluss
müssen wir sowieso glauben.
Wir sind auch zum Glauben
an die Wissenschaft verdammt.
Ob ich an einen Gott glaube
oder an die Evolution,
macht am Schluss
keinen so grossen Unterschied.
Ich selbst kann wissenschaftliche
Dinge nicht nachprüfen,
d.h., ich muss einfach
diesen Resultaten glauben.
Dem Einzelnen bleibt im Leben
sowieso nichts anderes übrig
als den grössten Teil
einfach zu glauben.
* Sphärische Musik *
Ist das ein spezieller Ort für dich?
Ja, diesen Ort hat mir vor langer
Zeit mal Andreas Dobler gezeigt,
er ist bildender Künstler.
Seine Mutter
wusch immer Steine an einer Quelle,
gab uns diese Steine in die Tasche
und sagte, das gebe gute Energie,
dann habe man gute Ideen
zum Arbeiten.
Das wendeten wir ein Jahr an
und uns ging es wirklich gut.
Dann sagte Dobler mal,
er kenne einen Ort,
der eine noch viel stärkere Wirkung
habe als die Steine der Mutter.
Dann hat er mir das gezeigt.
Das ist der Kraftort von Emma Kunz.
Du kannst dich freuen.- Ich war
noch nie hier, ich bin gespannt.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Schau jetzt. Der Wahn, oder?
* Mystischer Frauengesang *
Das ist Wahnsinn, nicht?- Ja.
- Spürst du etwas?
Es ist einfach schön. Aber vielleicht
bin ich nicht so empfänglich.
Wieso ist der Ort für dich speziell?
- Jetzt ist es etwas schwierig.
An so einen Ort
muss man allein gehen,
damit man wirklich etwas spürt,
man muss vorbereitet gehen.
Was ist es, das du spürst?
Ist es Gott oder ist es die Natur?
Oder was ist das für dich?
- Es ist eine Kraft.
Es ist ein ganz sanftes Kribbeln,
das von unten hochkommt.
Es geht einem einfach gleich gut,
mir ist jetzt wohl.- Okay.
Wie hast du es mit dem Glauben?
Sagst du: "Ich bin gläubig,
ich bin ein spiritueller Mensch"?
Ich sage mal: Ich möchte glauben,
ich möchte gern glauben,
dass ausserhalb von uns
noch etwas anderes ist.
Ja, du möchtest.
Aber du schaffst es nicht?
Ich arbeite immer wieder daran,
dass ich den Glauben daran
nicht verliere, ich sage es so.
Ich glaube, die Bibel ist
Weltliteratur, sogar Weltkulturerbe.
Und um die Bibel zu verstehen,
reicht ein Menschenleben wohl nicht.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht
meine Haltung:
Wenn man sagt, Gott seien auch
wir Menschen - daran glaube ich.
Und diesen Glauben an die Menschheit
will ich nie verlieren.
Ich glaube einfach
an die Menschheit.
Also am Schluss
an das Gute im Menschen?
Manche Leute sagen, es gebe
einen göttlichen Funken im Menschen.
So etwas?
- Ja, ganz genau. Den gibt es.
Und der wird vielleicht,
wenn man hier ist,
an einem solchen Kraftort,
etwas aufgeweckt.
Wie wenn man ein Bier trinkt,
dann wird man auch plötzlich
etwas gesprächiger.
Du glaubst also an einen Gott.
Glaubst du auch an einen Teufel?
Ist es
die fast schon kindliche Vorstellung,
die man früher hatte, von Gut
und Böse? Ist das für dich real?
Ich glaube nicht an einen Teufel
mit Hörnern in einer Höhle.
An einen solchen Teufel
glaube ich nicht.
Aber ich glaube, dass wir Menschen -
so viel Gutes wir in uns haben,
so viel Schlechtes
haben wir leider auch in uns.
Damit umzugehen und das zu bändigen,
das nenne ich manchmal den Teufel.
Was suchen denn Menschen im Glauben?
Diese Sendung heisst
"Macht Glauben glücklich?"
Sucht man Glück?
Oder was sucht man im Glauben?
Ich glaube, man sucht schlussendlich
einen Ausgleich zu seinen Schwächen.
Wir alle haben Schwächen,
verzweifeln manchmal,
wir haben Ängste und alles Mögliche.
Ich glaube,
man sucht darin einfach etwas Halt.
Und auch ...
Am meisten fürchten wir ja immer,
wenn wir nicht wissen, was passiert.
Man ahnt etwas Schlimmes,
aber man weiss nicht.
Davor fürchten wir uns am meisten.
Ich glaube,
wenn man sich einer höheren Macht
oder einem Gebet anvertraut,
bringt man es genau auf den Punkt.
Man lernt, genau zu formulieren,
worum es eigentlich geht.
Auch für sich selbst plötzlich Klar-
heit bekommen, wo die Ängste sind.
Richtig.
Wenn man diese mal erkennt
und benennen kann,
ist eine grosse Kraft der Angst
schon mal weg.
Macht dich dein Glaube glücklich?
Ja, natürlich nicht nur.
Also, das ...
Sonst wäre ich Pfarrer geworden.
Das allein reicht nicht.
Es wäre schön.
Es ist also ein Teil.
Es ist ein Teil, ja, der mithilft,
dass man glücklich ist.
Man kann sich ja freiwillig bedienen
von diesem Metaphysischen.
Es ist jedem freigestellt,
ob er es will.
Wenn er das Gefühl hat: "Nein,
mich macht es nicht glücklich",
soll er es doch bleiben lassen.
Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt
etwas Zeit in dieser Grotte,
um über all das nachzudenken,
was du gesagt hast.- Gut.
* Mystischer Frauengesang *
* Sphärische Musik *
Ich glaube, Sie sind
die erste "ungläubige Pfarrerin",
die ich in meinem Leben treffe.
Ella de Groot,
Pfarrerin von Muri-Gümligen.
Sie sagen, es gebe keinen Gott
und es gebe auch kein Jenseits.
Ich möchte zuerst etwas korrigieren:
Ungläubig bin ich nicht.
Ich habe einen ganz starken Glauben.
Aber nicht
an einen personalen Gott im Himmel.
Wie war es für Sie, als Sie wussten:
"Ich kann nicht mehr anderes",
"Ich muss hinstehen"?
Verursacht das Existenzängste?
Einfach war es nicht.
Es wurde eigentlich durch
einen Fernsehgottesdienst ausgelöst
am Karfreitag 2012.
Aufgrund dieses Fernsehgottesdiensts
gab es ein Interview
in der Sendung "Perspektiven"
mit Heidi Kronenberg.
Sie hat mir damals
diese Gretchenfrage gestellt.
Ich sagte, wir müssten aufhören
zu glauben, dass es Wahrheiten gibt.
Wahr ist in dem Sinn nichts.
Aber der Punkt ist:
Religion, Kirche, Sie als Pfarrerin
sind eigentlich
für uns als Gemeindemitglieder die,
die uns sagen können müsste,
wie es ist.
Wenn Sie das selbst nicht mehr können
und mir mehr Fragen geben
als Antworten liefern können,
frage ich mich, warum ich überhaupt
in eine Kirche gehen soll.
Ich habe keine Antwort
auf die Warum-Frage.
Wenn mich eine Frau fragt:
"Warum ist in meinem Umkreis
so viel Leid passiert?",
ist meine Antwort: "Die Warum-Frage
kann ich nicht beantworten."
Und deshalb
bin ich keine Autoritätsperson,
die sagt: "So ist es."
"Das sagt die Kirche,
wir kennen es so."
Der Mensch
hat eine Eigenverantwortung,
sein eigenes Denken,
seine Selbstständigkeit.
Und die Menschen wollen
ein authentisches Gegenüber.
Das war meine Erfahrung,
als ich danach freier geredet habe.
Wir gehen jetzt
auf dem Alten Kirchweg.
Ich bin ein wenig von diesem
Alten Kirchweg abgewandert.
Ich habe einen neuen Weg gesucht
und bin immer noch daran,
diesen neuen Weg zu suchen.
Das habe ich mit meinen
Gemeindemitgliedern gemacht.
Welche Reaktionen haben Sie erfahren?
- Genau das:
"Du formulierst das, was ich
eigentlich schon lange denke."
Ich bin befreit, ich hatte
unglaublich viele Reaktionen
von Menschen, die mir geschrieben
oder gesagt haben:
"Ich kann atmen,
ich habe Raum bekommen."
Einige Leute, die ich getroffen habe,
suchen in der Kirche
das Bewusstsein, dass es etwas gibt,
das grösser ist als wir,
z.B. jemanden, der unser Leben lenkt,
uns positiv unterstützt,
vielleicht auch unser Schicksal
in den Händen hält.
Die suchen das.
Wenn Sie sagen,
den einen Gott gebe es so gar nicht,
geht für sie
das Wesen des Glaubens verloren.
Es ist lustig: Meine Mutter ist 88,
wohnt in Holland
und ich sagte ihr am Telefon,
ich habe ein Gespräch
mit jemandem vom Fernsehen
darüber, ob Glauben glücklich macht.
Sie sagte mir am Telefon:
"Ob Glauben glücklich macht?"
"Das bedeutet wahrscheinlich,
dass es dann um Gott geht,
den Glauben an Gott."
Ich sagte, ich lasse mich
überraschen, welche Fragen kommen.
Aber sagen wir mal:
Macht der Glaube an Gott glücklich?
Dann sagte sie ...
Und sie ist ...
Reden über den Glauben ist für sie
noch schlimmer als reden über Sex.
Das ist etwas so Intimes,
das geht fast nicht.
Aber sie sagte dann:
"Nein, das macht nicht glücklich."
Da war ich völlig überrascht.
Dass sie sagt, der Glaube an Gott
mache nicht glücklich.- Genau.
Warum sagte sie das so?
Weil dieses Gottesbild
beziehungslos ist.
Es ist nur auf ihr Ich bezogen.
"Ich wünsche mir einen Gott,
der mein Leben so lenkt,
nach meinen Vorstellungen."
Und dann läuft das Leben nicht so,
wie man es sich erhofft hat.
Und das Gefühl:
"Gott hat mich verlassen
und mein Leben war unter dem Strich
nicht so glücklich
und ich habe doch immer geglaubt
und 'gottgefällig' gelebt ..."
Ich habe alles richtig gemacht
und doch ist es am Schluss ...
Und dann mit 88
eine Art Lebensbilanz:
"Nein, der Glaube an einen Gott,
der mein Leben lenkt,
macht mich nicht glücklich."
Ja, das ...
Was ist es denn am Schluss,
das der Glaube uns anzubieten hat?
Angenommen,
es gibt den einen Gott nicht.
Was ist es,
das der Glaube uns geben kann,
das unser Leben glücklicher macht?
Sie fragen mich jetzt,
woran ich glaube
und ob dieser Glaube
glücklich macht.
Ich sagte zu Beginn ...
Jetzt kann ich die Frage
noch mal so stellen:
Woran glauben denn Sie
und macht Ihr Glaube glücklich?
Der macht glücklich.
Ich sagte zu Beginn,
ich sei ein sehr gläubiger Mensch.
In dem Sinn: Ich glaube ans Leben.
Und das macht glücklich.
Ich glaube, dass das Leben im Ganzen
einen Sinn hat.
Und was dieser Sinn genau ist,
ist von Moment zu Moment
wieder unterschiedlich.
Den Gesamtsinn kenne ich auch nicht.
Das ist ...
Es ist nicht, dass wir irgendwann
in den Himmel kommen.- Nein, nein!
Das lese ich heraus.
- An einen Himmel glaube ich nicht.
Nein, der Sinn des Lebens ist,
hier in Beziehung zu leben.
Und das Gefühl von Verbundenheit
im Leben, von Beziehung,
das macht glücklich.
* Mystische, sphärische Musik *
Welchen Trost gibt es denn,
wenn man nicht sagen kann,
es gebe ein Jenseits,
in dem sich alle wiedersehen,
gerade bei schlimmen Todesfällen,
wenn z.B. ein Kind stirbt,
beim Suizid eines Menschen.
Welchen Trost hat der Glaube denn
überhaupt noch anzubieten?
Da sein.
Mit aushalten.
Keine Dinge formulieren, die nicht
von den Leuten selbst kommen.
Ich kann doch niemandem
einen Trost auferlegen.
Ich kann nur da sein
in diesem schweren Moment.
Oder auch dabei helfen,
praktische Dinge zu machen.
Und v.a. nachfragen:
"Was brauchst du?
Was brauchst du von mir?"
Ähm ...
Trost besteht nicht aus Worten.
Trost besteht aus einer Haltung.
Macht Glauben glücklich?
Mit dieser Frage
bin ich in diese Sendung gestartet.
Geendet bin ich hier,
mit Ella de Groot.
Macht Glauben glücklich?
Und wenn ja, welcher?
Glauben, dass mein Leben im Ganzen
des Lebens einen Sinn macht.
Es gibt verschiedene Momente
dieses Gefühls, berührt zu werden.
Und das macht glücklich,
wenn man diese Berührung spürt.
* Mystische, sphärische Klänge *